intensive search for Benjamin Foster
strangely ended where it began at a home
where police say he bound and tortured
his victim nearly killing her
pops and bangs rang out on what
neighbors say is a usually quiet street
in Grants Pass a small city in Southwest
Oregon
they approached behind large Shields
assembling in a line then moved in after
the standoff Foster was brought to the
hospital where police say he died from a
self-inflicted gunshot wound on Tuesday
police posted a photo of Foster from
earlier in the day where you can see him
walking a dog in town that prompted law
enforcement to swarm the area last week
police got close to catching the
36-year-old some 20 miles away but he
escaped there they did charge a
68-year-old woman accused of helping him
get away and warned the public that he
was still active on dating apps